سامر بيان وزاره الخارجيه العراقيه ما
الذي تضمنه من تفاصيل اخرى بخصوص اجال
تنفيذ هذا الاتفاق وان كانت الرؤيه
العراقيه تتقاطع مع الرؤيا الامريكيه
بخصوص شروط بدء هذا الخفض التدريجي
لمستشاريه
تحد بالضبط مريم الحديث الرسمي هنا في
بغداد بدا ب بنجاح بمفرده نجاح المفاوضات
بين العراق بين الحكومه العراقيه
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه بعد ليله
واحده من رساله امريكيه من واشنطن نقلتها
السفيره الامريكيه لدى بغداد وسلمتها الى
وزير الخارجيه الذي بدوره ارسلها الى رئيس
الوزراء ووصفها بارساله المهمه مصادر
للجزيره قالت من داخل مكتب رئيس الوزراء
زراء بان هذه الرساله
تتضمن مطالبه امريكيه بتحديد لجنه وموعد
لبدء مفاوضات انسحاب قوات التحالف الدولي
من الاراضي العراقيه اليوم في البيان
الرسمي الذي صدر عن الخارجيه العراقيه
تحدث عن نجاح هذه المفاوضات يبدو بانها
استمرت لفتره ليست بالقليله بين اللجنه
الثنائيه بين بغداد وواشنطن ووسط وصلت الى
اتفاق من وجهه نظر الحكومه العراقيه من
وجهه نظر بغداد الرسميه التي تتحدث عن
الاتفاق على تحديد مده تواجد قوات التحالف
الدولي في العراق ما يعني القوات
الامريكيه باعتبارها تاتي على راس قوات
التحالف هنا في داخل الاراضي العراقيه وان
المفاوضات جرت بين بغداد وواشنطن يتحدثون
عن ان حتى مع انسحاب هذه القوات او
الاتفاق على تحديد موعد للانسحاب التدريجي
من الاراضي العراقيه فهذا لا يعني بقطع
العلاقات بشكل كامل مع هذه الدول المنضوي
ضمن التحالف الدولي قالوا بان التعاون بين
التحالف الدولي والحكومه العراقيه سيستمر
ولكن بشكل منفرد مع دول التحالف الدولي
على اعتبار ان هذا التعاون سياتي في
مجالات عده ليست بعيده عنها حتى المجالات
الامنيه والعسكريه على مستوى التدريب
والتجهيز والمستوى الاستخباراتي ولكن لا
مهام قتاليه لقوات التحالف والقوات
الامريكيه في الاراضي العراقيه بحسب
الحكومه خصوصا بعد ازدياد وتصاعد حده
الهجمات الهجوم والهجوم المضاد بين فصائل
عراقيه منضو في المقاومه
والاسلاميه العراقيه والرد الامريكي
المستمر على مواقع لهذه الفصائل تقول
الحكومه العراقيه بانها مواقع تتبع هيئه
الحشد الشعبي الرسميه المؤسسه العسكريه
التي تتبع رئيس الوزراء بصفته القائد
العام للقوات المسلحه